معنا من اسطنبول الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي العقيده الركن حاتم كريم
الفلاحي عقيده الفلاحي اهلا بك تصريح رئيس
منظمه المحاربين القدامى فيه اكثر من
اشاره واكثر من رساله واكثر من اعتراف
الاهم انه قال انه لم يسبق الراى كثافه
اصابات الجنود الاسرائيليين كما يحدث الان
ما الذي يحاول ايدان كليمان لفته انتباه
السلطات الاسرائيليه
اليه
نعم لا شك هو في هذا التصريح يحاول لفت
الانتباه الى ان هناك اعداد كبيره من
الجرحى وهؤلاء سيكلف الخزينه الاسرائيليه
اموال طائله خصوصا ما بعد انتهاء هذه
الحرب خصوصا الجرح المعوقين من هؤلاء لان
هؤلاء لا يستطيعون العوده الى الى الخدمه
مره ثانيه ولا يستطيعون العمل وبالتالي
سيعانون من اشكالات صحيه هذه الاشكالات
الصحيه ستكون بمردوده اقتصاديه على الدوله
هذا اولا الامر الاخر بان هذه الاعداد
الكبيره قد تعكس للشارع الصهيوني مدى الع
العمليات التي تجري في قطاع غزه وفشل هذه
العمليات في تحقيق شيء وبالتالي هناك
خسائر كبيره جدا يجب ان تنتبه اليها ينتبه
اليها المجتمع وتنتبه اليها القيادات لان
هناك عمليه تعتيم على الخسائر التي او
الاعداد التي يحاول الجيش ان ان ان يعلنها
من خلال شاشات التلفاز ومن خلال المؤتمرات
الصحفيه وهذا سوف يؤثر بشكل كبير جدا على
العمليات العسكريه اذا ما تم الاعلان
الاعداد الحقيقيه لذلك هم الان في مازق
حقيقي اما ان يعلنون الاعداد الحقيقيه
وهذا سيتسبب باشكال حقيقيه في الداخل
الصهيوني او انهم يتكتمون على هذه الاعداد
ولكنها ستظهر هذه في الفتره القادمه وايضا
ستكون عرضه للمسائله القانونيه سواء على
مستوى القيادات العسكريه او سواء على
المستوى القيادات السياسيه التي صمتت او
اعطت الاوامر بعدم اعلان هذه الخسائر حتى
بالارقام
المعلنه وان كانت ربما بعيده عن الواقع
عقيده الفلاحي تثير القلق في وسط او في
اوساط الاسرائيليين اداء كهذا للجيش
الاسرائيلي وخسائر بهذا الحجم في ثلاثه
اشهر كيف تجعلنا نقيم ربما الجيش
الاسرائيلي ما الذي اختلف الان في الجيش
الاسرائيلي ما قبل وما بعد هذه الحرب التي
ستنهي شهرها الثالث بعد ايام
نعم لا شك بانه هذا الجيش كانت له هاله
كبيره قبل ان قبل احداث السابع عشر السابع
من اكتوبر الماضي وبالتالي عندما نتكلم
نتكلم عن الجيش الذي يحتل المرتبه الرابعه
في هذه المنطقه وعلى العالم على المرتبه
الثام عشر اذا هو يمتلك من القدرات
والامكانيات العسكريه ما تمن يكونه ان
يكون من القوات المتقدمه في المنطقه ولكن
الاحداث التي جرت اعتق اتقد وهذه الحرب
التي دخلها في قطاع غزه بينت بان هذا
الجيش الذي كان ينظر اليه بانه الجيش
الاقوى في المنطقه اخذ هذا الجيش الان
يتكبد خسائر كبيره جدا باسلحه بسيطه اذا
ما جئنا الى موازين القوى اردنا ان ناخذ
ان ناخذ الاسلحه التي تمتلكها فصائل
المقاومه هي لا تعني شيء بالميزان العسري
قياسا بما يمتلكه الجيش الصهيوني من
امكانيات وقدرات ولكن يبدو بان هذا الجيش
فشل في توظيف هذه الامكانيات والقدرات
بشكل صحيح في ساحه المعركه وهناك اشكاليه
في قله الخبره بالنسبه للقاده الميدانيين
وقله القدرات البدنيه وقله الخبرات
القتاليه بالنسبه للجندي المقاتل على في
ساحه المعركه هذا الامر ادى الى ارتفاع
نسبه الخسائر بشكل كبير جدا يضاف الى ذلك
بانه هناك فشل استخباراتي في بناء في بناء
الخطط التي تعم تعتمد عليه الخطه العسكريه
او
التعبويه نعم العقيد الركن حاتم كريم
الفلاحي الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي من
اسطنبول شكرا جزيلا
لك